una campaña puerta a puerta con el
objetivo de atraer al electorado latino
a participar en los comicios del 3 de
noviembre el voto latino siempre fue
clave en las elecciones estadounidenses
pero este año los hispanos representan
la primera minoría étnica con 32
millones de votantes elegibles el 13 3%
de la población total sin embargo la
participación entre la comunidad latina
ha sido tradicionalmente baja
lucia salinas quiere cambiar este rumbo
nos ha quitado lo de migración de está
acá ha quitado el tps eso es mucha
historia y yo creo que ahorita muchas de
nuestras comunidades personas que somos
inmigrantes hijos de inmigrantes que
estoy pueden votar que hay muchos
jóvenes que están molestos de eso no
todos los hispanos tienen el privilegio
de votar hay al menos 11 millones de
inmigrantes indocumentados en el país el
estatus migratorio de maria jose le
niega el derecho al voto pero no le
impide movilizarse y hacer campaña en su
comunidad no puedo votar pero también
podemos puedo yo meter mi granito verdad
a estar aquí a buscando por cuando por
una candidata que nos tome en cuenta y
le importa la verdad importa' del vino
de nuestro bienestar y más específico y
no para la gente indocumentada
históricamente los hispanos se han
identificado con los demócratas
joe biden sigue liderando los sondeos
con un 67 por ciento frente al 24 por
ciento del presidente de donald trump
pero el voto latino no es homogéneo y
podría ser decisivo en estados pendular
es como florida arizona o pensilvania
por ello ambos candidatos apelan a su
voto crucial si hemos logrado más para
los hispanoamericanos en 47 meses de lo
que yo va a ir en ha logrado en 47 años
vamos a estar en una situación en la que
no podemos hacer esto es no podemos
hacerlo sin todos ustedes no podemos
ganar sin la comunidad de la economía la
atención médica y la gestión de la
pandemia son los principales temas para
los latinos en estos comicios